in this lecture we look at mao zedong's
effort to dramatically accelerate
china's economic development by
undertaking
a great leap forward distrustful of
khrushchev's revisionism
now abandoned the soviet model of
socialist construction
and in 1958 he struck out in a new
and uncharted direction hoping to
leapfrog the russians
and beat them to the promised land of
communism
it was an audacious gamble and it failed
miserably for various reasons
the soviet model had not proved to be a
very good fit for china
for one thing soviet-style socialism
spawned economic free riders as we saw
for another
it was ill-suited to china's demographic
and economic conditions
china had little advanced technology for
industrial development
few world-class scientists and engineers
little virgin land to bring under
cultivation
and a massive unskilled rural population
that was still using thousand-year-old
farming techniques
the great leap began not as a grandiose
blueprint
for human social engineering but as a
series of ad hoc
responses to specific developmental
problems
the programs of the great leap were
often improvised and experimental
and some of them made reasonable sense
at least in theory
all too soon however the enterprise spun
out of control
the first major innovation introduced at
the end of 1957
involved the mobilization of tens of
millions of collective farmers
during the slack winter season when the
demand for field labor
was sharply reduced instead of sitting
around in their villages through the
long chinese winter
peasants could be put to work building
large-scale water conservancy projects
dams reservoirs dikes and canals
the concept was rather simple and dated
back to ancient imperial times
large-scale water conservation projects
meant
higher stable crop yields and stable
crop yields
meant greater tax revenues for the state
since china was short on both investment
capital and advanced technology
but long on raw unskilled human labor
idle male laborers were conscripted from
the villages
to do the heavy work of building water
management projects
using whatever simple tools they had at
hand
shovels picks and hoes
in some cases as many as ten thousand
peasants from up to a dozen or more
villages
were transported to a single work site
since the distances involved often
exceeded 10 or 15 miles
they were too great to be traveled on
foot in a single day
so temporary barracks were erected at
the work sites
where the laborers would remain for
weeks or even
months at a time returning home only
infrequently
to maintain discipline and morale among
the workforce
a rudimentary military style regimen was
introduced
workers arose at dawn to recorded bugle
calls
ate their meals in communal canteens and
marched in step to the work sites
their tools over their shoulders like
rifles
once there they synchronized their labor
to the sharp regular rhythms of work
chance participating laborers
received no paid compensation for their
work
though meals housing and transportation
were provided free of charge
perhaps inevitably this new militarized
form of large-scale labor-intensive
conservation work
was compared to the red army's conduct
of people's war
during the yen on period in fact
the entire enterprise was now portrayed
in the state media
as a people's war against nature
and this in turn set a militaristic tone
for the entire great leap forward to
follow
one key feature of the water management
campaign
was the marked absence of expert
scientific or
technical input blueprints were done on
the fly
often by inexperienced draftsman
surveying was slip shot
material specifications were mere
approximations based on crude estimates
of load-bearing capacities
and structural requirements the fact
that many of these huge
projects later failed or collapsed
because of design and construction flaws
did not immediately dampen the regime's
enthusiasm for the triumph of the human
spirit
in the can-do ethos of the great leap
forward
expert scientists engineers and
technical intellectuals
were denigrated as useless in practical
bookworms
while the politically mobilized red
peasants and cadres
were given credit for achieving amazing
feats of creativity
and daring with millions of male
laborers living on the construction
sites often for months at a time
the spring of 1958 saw a growing
shortage of able-bodied farm workers
in the villages as the busy spring
planting season approached
women were mobilized to work in the
fields
to conserve household labor domestic
chores
were now collectivized instead of each
woman cooking for her own family
a few women would prepare meals for
everyone in the village
child care was also managed on a
communal basis
with a few village grannies keeping
watch over all the local children
care for the elderly sick and disabled
was similarly arranged
on a large-scale basis
the net effect of all of this was to
free up large numbers of women
from the demands of household domestic
chores
enabling them to participate in farm
labor while the men were away working on
conservation projects
chinese propagandists praised the new
system
for having liberated chinese women from
household drudgery
but it was women's liberation of a
rather strange
type since it involved the swapping of
one kind of drudgery
for another
by the late spring of 1958 several of
these ad hoc innovations had become more
or less permanent fixtures in china's
collective farms
communal dining halls were now the norm
they were lauded in party newspapers
as a breakthrough for their communist
spirit of
literally serving the people
in some areas rural cadres began to
experiment with enlarging the scale of
the existing collective farms
by amalgamating as many as 10 or even 20
neighboring villages
to form a single integrated
administrative unit
with populations as high as 10 000 or
even
20 000 people
the mass media were quick to applaud
such experiments
as the first sprouts of communism and
mao himself was delighted with the
sudden
upsurge of enthusiasm for these things
that he called
newborn socialist things
on an inspection tour of rural ghanan
province
in the early summer of 1958 mao visited
one of these newly amalgamated
large-scale
collectives impressed by the evident
enthusiasm of the local peasants and
cadres
now asked for the name of their new
organization
wei xing ranmin gung sha came the answer
the sputnik
people's commune
on mao's return trip to beijing a
reporter from the people's daily
asked the chairman for his impression of
this new sputnik
people's commune mao's five-word
response
people's communes are good appeared the
next day
as a banner headline on the masthead of
the communist party's flagship newspaper
all over china rural officials now
hastened to emulate the sputnik
experience
mao had said people's communes are good
now
suddenly they began to pop up everywhere
like mushrooms after a spring rain
suddenly all roads to washing were
jammed with officials converging from
all parts of the country
seeking to learn the secrets of
organizing and running a people's
commune just what was a people's commune
and how did it work along with the
dramatic enlargement of china's
collective farms
extraordinary claims of unprecedented
crop yields began to appear in the
official media
in areas where people's communes had
been formed relatively early
the summer wheat harvest in 1958 was
said to have virtually
doubled from the previous year new
breakthroughs in productivity were
reported almost
daily as a wave of unbridled optimism
spread like wildfire
new innovations in farm techniques now
began to be widely reported and
popularized
a revolutionary method of planting rice
called deep plowing and close
planting was promoted in the summer of
1958.
the theory behind it was that if two
tons of rice could be grown on a given
plot of land
by planting the seedlings 12 inches
apart at a depth of 6 inches
then far larger yields could in
principle be achieved
by planting the young seedlings twice as
close together
at twice the depth and with twice as
much fertilizer
added per acre of rice
to facilitate deep plowing a new larger
type of farm plow was introduced
the two-wheel two-share plow
pulled by two fully grown men or a water
buffalo
it could dig a furrow up to 18 inches
deep
almost immediately claims of doubled or
even trebled crop yields were reported
in the party press
as rural officials across the country
competed among themselves to meet and
exceed
established norms of per-acre production
a famous photo printed in the people's
daily showed a group of children playing
happily
on the top of a thick rich plot of
mature rice plants
the plants in the photo were as thick as
a straw mattress
and they easily supported the weight of
the frolicking children
with the new larger size of the people's
communes it now became possible at least
in theory
to broadly diversify the rural economy
by introducing a large-scale division of
labor involving
thousands of peasants the communes could
it was argued
become entirely self-sufficient not
merely in
food production but in industry commerce
education and military training as well
no longer bound by the conventional
technocratic constraints of the old
soviet model
china was blazing a new and original
pathway
to the future
perhaps the most famous example of rural
economic diversification during the
great leap
was the notorious campaign to create
large amounts
of high quality steel in backyard
blast furnaces here again the idea was
to substitute large-scale mobilized
human labor
for the scientific technical and capital
requirements of making steel
in modern urban factories
in launching the new campaign mao
declared that his goal was to surpass
great britain in steel production
within 15 years
throughout the countryside millions of
peasants were conscripted
to build small-scale clay brick and
mortar kilns
operating around the clock the kilns
were fired to superheated temperatures
to keep the furnaces blazing all
available
rural fuel supplies were consumed
whole forests were denuded of trees and
all available household heating and
cooking coal
was requisitioned to supply the needed
pig
iron scrap metal was collected in every
village
including old farm tools bicycle parts
household pots
pans and utensils anything and
everything metallic was fed into the
furnaces
nothing was spared not even family walks
working night and day china's mobilized
peasants produced almost
3 million tons of backyard steel in 1958
approximately 15 pounds of steel for
every man
woman and child in rural china
the sudden spike in output represented a
30 percent
increase in the country's total steel
production for 1958
a few months later an obvious and
obviously exuberant chairman mao
revised his goal of catching up with
great britain
from 15 years down to only
three and still the innovations kept
coming
one problem that had long plagued rural
china was the prevalence of
grain-consuming pests
birds rats and insects as part of the
great leap
a people's war was launched to eliminate
the four leading crop-eating pests
in this new campaign sparrows were
designated public enemy number one
to reduce the sparrow population a
low-cost
labor-intensive strategy was devised
millions of peasants mainly women and
children and the elderly
were mobilized to bang pots and pans and
wave sticks and brooms
outdoors the resulting din frightened
the sparrows out of the trees and fields
and into the air
unable to land because of the intense
noise they would eventually drop from
exhaustion whereupon they were set upon
by crowds of people and strung onto
garlands
which were then displayed as trophies
those who killed the most sparrows were
given commendation as advanced
workers or sputniks tens of millions of
sparrows were killed in this way
by the mid-summer of 1958 a national
euphoria was in evidence
fueled by extreme claims of success in
the people's war against nature
and amplified by an overactive communist
propaganda machine
china's leaders began to believe that
they had discovered a shortcut to
communism
the ultimate nirvana
by the end of 1958 the country's 750
thousand collective farms had been
consolidated and
merged into just 23 000
people's communes each with an average
size
of 25 000 people
in the excitement of the moment it
escaped notice
that many if not most of the communes
had been set up in haste
without much planning or preparation
with mao already engaged in a contest of
egos with nikita khrushchev
the chinese leader was eager to prove
the superiority of china's newly
discovered pathway
to communist perfection to bolster
china's claims that people's communes
would hasten the arrival of pure
communism
mao gave his blessing to a new system of
income distribution
to pay china's communal farmers
instead of receiving payment
proportional to the work they performed
as in the past commune members now would
receive the bulk of their income
based on the communist distribution
principle
of to each according to his need
that is free supply
in the new system income entitlements
were calculated for different
demographic categories for men
women children and the elderly on the
basis of their average daily caloric
requirements
at the conclusion of each harvest 70
of the commune's distributable income
would be handed out according to these
entitlements
without regard to labor contribution
only 30 percent was awarded on the basis
of work
actually performed
to ensure that all remnants of
capitalism were thoroughly eradicated in
the new communes
the small private plots and domestic
animals that individual families had
been permitted to retain for their own
private use under collectivization
were now communized and rural free
markets where peasants had traditionally
sold or bartered their surplus produce
were summarily abolished across
china the wind of communism was blowing
with gale
force
to spur even greater increases in farm
output emulation contests were held
throughout the countryside
first the members of one commune would
pledge to double their grain output at
the next harvest
then a neighboring commune would counter
pledge to raise their grain harvest by
say 125
and so on those communes that met or
exceeded their pledges
were awarded the honorary title of
sputnik
by august of 1958 central party leaders
had become dizzy with success
believing that food was abundant they
ratcheted up communal
quotas for mandatory grain procurement
by the state
local officials who were painfully aware
that many of the reports were grossly
exaggerated
were nonetheless obligated to fulfill
the new higher quotas
clearly reluctant to offend their
superiors they lied to them
inflating their harvest estimates while
squeezing
every last drop of grain out of the
hapless peasants
who were forced to tighten their belts
just to survive
the result was a national orgy of
official exaggeration
and unreality at the very top of the
food chain
while at the bottom of the chain
hundreds of millions of peasants
began to suffer shortages
the engine driving this entire upward
spiral of inflated expectations
was mao zedong himself
by the late summer of 1958 mao had gone
all in in his competition with
khrushchev in effect
betting the house on the success of the
great leap
because of this he could not countenance
the loss of face that would accompany
any acknowledgement of failure
aware of the intensity of mao's feelings
his lieutenants
dared not question his judgment or
dampen his
enthusiasm
meeting in august of 1958 at the seaside
resort of baidaiku
not far from beijing chinese leaders
basked in their ostensible success
china's 1958 grain harvest had it was
estimated
exceeded 450 million tons
surpassing even the united states and
party leaders were told that the country
could produce as much rice as it wanted
to
now even went on record as suggesting
that everyone should eat not
three meals a day but five
summer's end the party's propagandists
were proclaiming unprecedented
breakthroughs in
every realm of human endeavor from steel
making and grain production to medical
science
even athletic competition
on the ground in the provinces however
the gap between
rhetoric and reality was becoming
painfully
apparent although the initial crop
harvest in the summer of 1958
was in fact larger than average a number
of serious problems had begun
to emerge when the first heavy summer
rains fell in 1958
many of the dams canals dikes and
reservoirs constructed the previous
winter
began to fail causing inundation of
hundreds of thousands of acres of crop
land
of the 500 largest reservoirs under
construction
in the winter of 5758 more than 200 were
abandoned within two years
nor did the great leaps water
conservation failures end there
in 1975 a huge dam
built in 1958 in hanan province during
the height of the leap
collapsed causing an estimated 200
000 deaths the largest single
dam disaster in human history
the main causes of failure were
inadequate engineering know-how
and the routine use of substandard
construction materials
the maoist emphasis on mass mobilization
over careful planning
on ideological redness over technical
expertise
had created not miracles but vast
misfortune the 1958 experiment with
close planting and deep plowing
also proved a failure rice seedlings it
turned out
could not be successfully transplanted
at a depth of more than 10 inches
it tended to kill the dealt delicate
seedlings
and doubling the application of
fertilizer per acre
tended to burn the young seedlings
rather than nourish them
it was later revealed that the famous
people's daily photo that showed
children playing on a thick bed
of clothes planted rice had been faked
by local cadres
for the benefit of visiting party
dignitaries
the backyard steel furnaces were the
next to fail
although large amounts of scrap metal
were successfully melted down and forged
into crude steel the resulting products
were unusable
the steel's composition was not
standardized its smelting temperatures
varied widely
its chemical alloys were impure and its
tensile strength was so poor
that it tended to crack under stress
once again the ascendancy of red
ideology over
expert planning and engineering had led
to failure
to make sme to make matters worse in the
obsessive drive to keep the backyard
furnaces firing 24
7 the reckless denuding of forests and
underbrush from rural hillsides
created a severe shortage of fuel for
cooking and heating
as well as a massive problem of soil
erosion
the effects of these environmental
disasters are still being felt in rural
china today
some 50 years later
the systematic elimination of grain
devouring sparrows was also of dubious
value
though millions of sparrows were killed
it turns out
that the tiny birds devoured their
weight in insects
without sparrows to control the insect
population
crop damage was even greater than before
on top of all this the much vaunted free
supply system
introduced in the people's communes also
turned out to be a failure with 70
percent of a commune's income
distributed to members without regard
for work performed
the free rider problem worsened
considerably
the communes were so large and so
impersonal
it was virtually impossible to monitor
individual work performance
let alone to punish those who failed to
pull their weight
under such circumstances the incentive
to work diligently
was further diluted field management was
done carelessly
planting was haphazard and mature grain
was left to rot
in the fields
the combination of deeply flawed
technical innovations
diminished incentives to work hard and a
false sense of economic abundance and
personal entitlement
added up to a recipe for catastrophe
with mao still basking in his late
summer euphoria
urging people to eat five meals a day
communal granaries in the autumn
began to run dangerously low and meals
certainly
served in communal kitchens became
plainer
sparser and less appetizing
as one peasant recalled
at first an individual got 18 ounces of
food a day
but later there was so little grain in
our storehouse
that they reduced it to nine ounces with
that you couldn't even make steamed buns
so they made a soup a kind of gruel
complaints began to pour into newspapers
around the country
bemoaning the poor quality of communal
food and the careless indifference of
communal cooks
rice stalks wheat chaff and pieces of
corn husk
now found their way into communal meals
with increasing regularity
and the gruel got thinner and thinner
by the end of the year the bubble of
irrational exuberance
had begun to burst crop yields in the
second half of 1958
were much lower than in the first half
and the adverse effects of the wasteful
backyard steel campaign and the
ill-advised free supply system
were beginning to be felt yet quotas for
compulsory grain delivery to the state
remained unrealistically high when
peasants complained that they couldn't
meet their inflated grain quotas
mao accused them of hoarding and
dividing surplus grain among themselves
and he ordered rural cadres to search
their homes
and seize the grain
caught uncomfortably between the demands
of their superiors
and the frantic pleas of the commune
members local cadres did as they were
told
in many areas they hired thugs to search
peasants homes for concealed grain
beating up anyone who resisted
in a number of cases sympathetic rural
cadres committed suicide rather than
comply with such inhumane treatment
by the winter of 1959 the party central
committee
and even mao himself recognized that
something had gone seriously wrong at a
meeting in late february
mao grudgingly acknowledged that leftist
excesses had created problems
and he now ordered a reduction in
compulsory steel
and grain quotas and a readjustment of
the free supply system
to strengthen work incentives in the
people's communes
although mao gave ground on some of the
particulars of the great leap
he was too stubborn to acknowledge
failure especially to nikita khrushchev
and so even as the grain supply
situation became progressively worse
now unilaterally stepped up china's
exports of grain to the soviet union
in repayment of stalin's 1949 loan
in the face of a growing crisis a few of
mao's lieutenants began to question the
inflated claims of success
previously afraid to speak out for fear
of offending the chairman
they now began to raise their voices in
dissent
and in the summer of 1959 their newfound
courage presented mao zedong
with the single biggest challenge of his
career
to date next time
defense minister pung dawai confronts
chairman mao
[Music]